since I am such a culture vulture
hip-hop pop music Maven the producers
have teed me up a music video they say I
have to see this to give my expert young
hip cool fresh take on it okay and I
know absolutely nothing about music
video all I know is that it is sponsored
by expressvpn more from expressvpn later
the title of this music video is I don't
know My Two Dads and Me by Ridley Jones
maybe this is a parody I don't know all
right let's uh let's see
it's on Netflix
there you are ready for a royal Feast
that's it am I I am hungry hey hungry
nice to meet you kidding kidding mummy
dad joke wait you're is mitz Friends hi
a hi hi we're the dads I'm Otten this is
cozy it's really nice to finally meet
you ismas told us all about you nice to
meet you too she's told us nothing about
you well then you all just have to stay
for dinner we'll go get extra play
settings you know what's amazing put a
pause here so they're obviously pushing
the not so subtle gay agenda as Disney
execs call it but here they even have to
make one of the dads look like a woman
and it's by putting on that sort of
Egyptian headdress that in the cartoon
looks like a woman's hair because if it
were just too you know Butch looking
Village People or something that would
read as two radical people would realize
how insane that is so they've got a kind
of currently get it in there and and
they lure you in by making the scene
kind of look like a husband and a wife
but then the wife says no I'm actually a
man okay keep going this man you aren't
trying to hide the fact that you have
two dads were you because that seems
awesome to me that seems totally awesome
I hate my mom my mom has absolutely
nothing to add to raising me yeah I
think it's totally awesome to have two
dads what do we need women for let's get
them out of society
hey where are the women at I wish I
didn't have a mom I'm how great is it
that your father created you in a Petri
dish with the express intention of
depriving you of your natural mother to
whom you have a right or adopted you and
also took away the opportunity for a
husband and a wife in an actual marriage
to adopt and raise you and give you the
benefits of both a father and a mother
that's just totally awesome you know
when people are thinking about things
that they would desire that they don't
have in this modern world a big one is
privacy from the government and these
World corporations do you know sending
data over an unencrypted internet
connection it's like sending a postcard
your message is wide open for the
mailman and any other nosy individual to
see whenever you are connected to an
unencrypted internet Network on your
phone computer tablet or TV you're
sending countless pieces of information
out into the digital world that can be
seen and intercepted by pretty much
anyone a VPN or virtual private Network
creates a secure tunnel between your
device and the Internet it's like
putting your postcard card in an
envelope so that no one can read your
letter before it gets to the person
you're sending it to expressvpn is the
VPN that I trust to keep my data secure
expressvpn creates a secure encrypted
tunnel between your device and the
internet so that hackers can't steal
your personal data your passwords your
financial details on and on hackers make
serious cash selling personal
information on the dark web but
expressvpn makes it easier than ever to
keep your information safe you just fire
up the app click one button and you are
instantly protected plus expressvpn
works on all your devices so you can
stay secure on the go secure your online
data today at expressvpn.com michaelyt
and get three extra months for free
that's expressvpn.com michaelyt
expressvpn.com Michael y t alright back
to the music video I guess what no
having two dads is the best I get to
hear twice the dad jokes and none of the
mom jokes
[Music]
I must admit I love the Banquets and the
Bowing and omra this Crown feels perfect
on my head
but there are days when even with the
sweet subservient cow Towing I'd like to
be a normal kid instead
sometimes I long to be an ordinary
family
just My Two Dads and me
away my subjects don't upon their leader
oh wow oh my gosh
that's amazing because she's saying
sometimes I long to be an ordinary
family and you say oh of course you do
because you're very confused and selfish
fathers these two men have have placed
their own desires disorder desires over
your good and well-being and you long to
have a mother because babies need
mothers but then Netflix
totally perverts that and says no no the
thing that she Longs for is to be poor
you know the thing that she's upset
about is that she's rich and Powerful
because the setup of this whole cartoon
is that her her homosexual fathers are
actually you know reigning in Egypt
which is another little trick here by
the way because they're taking this this
thing which is completely anachronistic
and they're saying oh no homosexual
marriage and adoption and the idea of
two homosexual guys is the heads of a
family which is a concept that has
existed for exactly five seconds no that
dates all the way back to ancient Egypt
of course it doesn't it's completely
unheard of but that's another little
trick here because people who are
watching this are going to have no
historical context especially if they're
kids and so they're going to say oh of
course this is totally normal it's just
a process of normalizing something that
is totally abnormal and then to say no
no what I long for is just to be totally
broke not that I long for my mom who
cares about my mom I'm totally a fan
you wouldn't think a queen could Tire of
her own personal grape feeder but every
now and then I guess she can
sometimes there's something I would
rather be than royalty
It's My Two Dads and me
this is truly nauseating this is so sick
and perverse coming from Netflix I guess
this is why daily wire needs to create
100 million dollars worth of kids
contact I don't know if I pay for my
Netflix subscription I might just be
using someone else's passcode I don't
really remember but I might just have to
cancel Netflix I can't have my money
going to that that is so
wrong my expectations were low maybe
some lib music video but that was so
much worse it's a cartoon to totally
distort kids Minds
all right that's it please send in
better songs next time please oh gosh
give me some kind of palette cleanser I
don't know some
[Music]
see you next time
[Music]